here with reaction author this is the
book right here I have it in my hands of
the brand new book it's on amazon.com
hannity.com bookstores everywhere uh res
it's called resurrected Jesus uh the
Church of the New Testament it was
written by David Limbaugh who by the way
has been my lawyer for all my years of
media and also his daughter who is my
personal assistant who works right here
on Hannity of Fox News they wrote it
together uh David the book is awesome
I'm proud of you I hope everyone gets a
copy it is a great book and you have
helped me with my faith and I can't
thank you enough for that also with us
is Trump attorney Elena Haba and Fox
News legal analyst Greg Janet uh Jarrett
sorry uh Greg Alina let me start with
you let's start with this judge's
decision and what it means uh they got
his tax records attorney client
privileged information they got his
passports what didn't they get
they took everything they wanted to take
that's obviously evident the injunction
which means that they've stopped all
criminal investigations was granted
which is a great win for the Trump team
that is handling this matter
additionally we received an approval to
get a special Master which was exactly
what I had hoped would happen the doj as
you may recall was opposing this they
didn't want it and what the public had
assumed was a delay was in fact the fact
that and the judge mentioned this the
fact that the doj wasn't willing to
Grant a special Master when we requested
it prior so then we had to file a motion
the judge made the right decision in my
opinion we'll have a special master who
will take a look at everything that they
took give back the privileged
information the things that they
shouldn't have and stop any criminal
investigation that might be happening or
any investigation at all from preceding
dead in its tracks until that special
Master gets into play Greg I said from
day one that this was a fishing
Expedition taking the former president's
tax information taking his attorney
claim privilege information over 500
pages at least we're reading now taking
his medical records taking his passports
this is why that broad warrant and we
should see by the way the affidavit in
full not redacted this is why it was
always a fishing Expedition because of
certain sections that they used in the
Espionage Act
I agree it was protectual and by the way
I look forward to reading David and
Christian's book they're both gifted
writers and good luck to you
um look the judge seemed to be saying
here that Merrick Garland went too far
he grabbed too much and he gabbed too
much Whispering into the ears of the
media that hate Donald Trump derogatory
negative information about the contents
of the very documents that Garland seeks
to conceal
uh and and the judge talked about the
irreparable injury the potential harm
the indelible stain that the president
suffers as a consequence an effort to
convict him uh in the court of public
opinion but the judge also seemed very
skeptical uh about the volume the sheer
expanse of what the FBI went in and did
it Mar-A-Lago they vacuumed up
everything except the carpets and the
chandelier eleven thousand documents
eighteen hundred more other items
described by the judge not to mention
520 documents that are confidential and
covered by the attorney-client privilege
uh and and that doesn't even include
executive privilege and this was the big
blow to Merrick Garland the judge
deflated his argument that Joe Biden has
the authority to nullify a former
president's executive privilege by
simply waving it the judge pointed out
talk there's a case before The Supreme
Court just this year in which the high
court suggested that you can't do that
that would render meaningless any
president's executive privilege so you
know this is a big blow to Merrick
Garland but he's not the kind of guy who
takes it sitting down I suspect he is
seriously considering an appeal David
let's get your take on this from a legal
perspective
well you know I I find it amazing that
people aren't up in arms about what's
going on especially in context of the
2016
refusal by the Democrats to accept the
election results and they by the way are
the threat to democracy not Donald Trump
and they fabricated that hoax and there
still hasn't been Justice for that and
now we we learned that they've
suppressed
bobolinsky's evidence and his testimony
is whistleblowing that ought to scare
the heck out of people why is the FBI
doing this why is Peter struck and why
are they so weaponized and politicized
and now we see this continuing pattern
and now we view that in the context of
what's going on today which is that
President former president Trump just
wants a special Master an objective
reviewer of these documents to tell us
whether they are legitimately seized and
what and whether some of them are
covered by executive uh privilege or
attorney-client privilege as Greg said
so what do they have to fear and yet
they do and you get get liberals like
Dan Rather who pretended to be a
objective journalist for 100 years
saying that it's some kind of conspiracy
and that Trump has manipulated this and
the judge behind this judge Cannon was
in his back pocket and and she issued
this order but why what are they afraid
of I asked what are they afraid of we
want transparency they want to keep it
secret they're the ones who are black
blacking out everything we are the ones
who want transparency I submit to you
that the side that wants transparency is
the side less to be suspicious of I'll
tell you this is going to get very
interesting now and we'll see whether
the judge goes with this next uh by the
way what a great thing uh and you
dedicated this book that you and Kristen
wrote the resurrected Jesus to uh your
brother Rush who we all miss dearly and
I hope people get a copy of it David
Limbaugh thank you Molina good to see
you as well and of course Greg always
great to have you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else